all right we are now live for the next
AMA it's uh July half the year is gone
as I'm highly conscious of uh so
let's get started there's already some
good questions aligned up uh pertaining
to a bunch of different things so David
asks how does stoicism handle a
situation with a spouse that has
dementia so the first thing to say and
this may seem a little bit Petty but I
think it's an important point to make
stoicism doesn't handle anything stoics
applying uh the principles and practices
of the philosophical system that we kind
of halfway have from Antiquity called
stoicism they handle these things and
it's not as if like there's a pat stoic
answer for each single thing as you find
out when you look at these people so you
know stoicism would
um suggest a bunch of
insights things to suggest to yourself
to keep in mind practices that you can
do and you know it'd be similar to other
things that you'd be dealing with with a
spouse who
is um in a challenging situation you
know
dementia is something that runs across a
spectrum there is like little as we call
them senior moments where people have
lapses and they're not quite getting
things all the way to like you have no
idea what's going on and all sorts of
things in between
and what would uh stoic do in in dealing
with you know a spouse somebody made a
lifelong commitment to who is suffering
from dementia well first of all you'd be
showing them a lot of understanding and
compassion and trying to realize the
situation that they're in and that they
didn't choose to you know not understand
things or forget things or anything
along those lines so you'd be pretty
uh forgiving towards them and you would
you know you would sort of like think
ahead to what sort of problems and
challenges that not only they're likely
to encounter but you're likely to
encounter as a result so you probably
would engage in some negative
visualization thinking about all right
this is probably not going to get better
this is going to get worse how am I
going to deal with the fact that my
spouse doesn't know who the people
around them are perhaps even who I am am
I able to handle this you know
I think stoicism can also be useful for
helping wean you away from negative
emotions and you know we could say
excessive reactions I mean if your
spouse has dementia that's going to suck
and you know it's probably not going to
get better over time but you can still
love them and they can still enjoy
things I mean my wife and I
um we're both in our 50s and one of the
things that we know is that music is
very important to us and that music can
be quite helpful for people who have
dementia and we may end up suffering
that so we're already sort of like
lining up playlists of music that helps
us reconnect and you know is that
necessarily tied to stoicism no but a
stoic would want to exercise Prudence
right and I think developing courage not
just in the sense of like facing fears
but being persevering would also be
important as well
so that I mean there's a lot more that
could be said about that that could be
like an entire Workshop I think but
we'll just leave that there because
there's already a lot of other questions
so Jacob says thoughts on UFOs and
aliens have you heard what the
Whistleblower David grush has said
uh good resources and philosophy the
implications of non-human intelligence
Among Us so three different things I
don't really have thoughts on UFOs and
aliens and any sort of like well worked
out sense I mean I like speculative
fiction I don't actually uh have any
reason to think that there are
unidentified flying objects or aliens
Among Us or anything like that so I you
know I don't really
think too much about that and I don't
know who David garage has said because
I'm not into UFO communities or anything
like that
um now interestingly
resources and philosophy for the
implications of non-human intelligence
Among Us so not just philosophy but
speculative fiction you know you could
think of speculative fiction as running
through a bunch of different
scenarios and thinking about like what
how should we approach as we call it
first Contact or the Revelation that
there would be aliens among us or
something like that
and it ranges the gamut I mean there
aren't any I mean there's probably
somebody out there who's written a book
philosophy of of you know
extraterrestrials or something but
that's not an area that I work in but I
would say that you know if they are
rational beings we could ask ourselves
questions like
are all rational beings similarly going
to be rational can they live together
well are they inevitably going to be
drawn into conflict or things like that
and I think there's a lot of great
speculations out there about that
um but that's all they are is
speculations at this point until we
actually run into
some bona fide aliens I suppose
uh Darth says where were there any
philosophers who stuttered yeah I'm sure
there have been plenty of philosophers
who have stuttered I actually had not a
philosophy Professor but a uh
anthropology Professor who stuttered and
we talked about it in class and how he
dealt with it and um so yeah there's
philosophers who've had all sorts of
interesting uh issues with with speech
do they write about their experience
with difficulty speaking did it
influence their philosophy I mean I I
haven't like nobody comes to mind but
I'm sure if you Google it you would
probably find some people recently in
say disability studies or something like
that who have written about that and
maybe it influenced their philosophy
nobody as I said comes to mind for me
but there I mean there are a lot of
philosophers who have had
let's say difficulties expressing
themselves you know Thomas Aquinas for a
long time was called the dumb Ox because
he was a big old guy and didn't say much
of anything and then when he did his
classmates were very surprised by how
smart he was because they thought he was
a big dummy
um so you know there's all sorts of
stuff like that
uh elianik says have there ever been any
philosophers who decided to stop or I
decided to stop reading because they
were taking me to a mentally unhealthy
place
um no I there's nobody who I decided to
stop reading I I know other people in
the field
who have said yeah I'm not going to read
this person because I find them
depressing or aggravating I mean for me
it's more like
am I getting anything out of the reading
this person's stuff given that I could
be reading other people's stuff so
um there's there's quite a few
philosophers whose works and they're
usually not great philosophers they're
kind of second rate or third right who
I've said yeah I'm not this is not worth
my time somebody else can read this
person
um
and I think that's perfectly legitimate
to do it's not as if you could read
everybody it's not as if you're under
some sort of moral imperative to give
everybody a chance or something like
that I I tend to think and this is a
little bit off topic that
you know it's your life you decide what
you want to read you know so if you
don't want to read hegel's phenomenology
of spirit you don't have to if you read
Nietzsche and you're like I don't like
this guy because he's kind of a prick
and he's uh unfair to other philosophers
I I think that's okay you don't you
don't have to necessarily read them
um but I haven't I haven't been so
influenced by
philosophers and what it is that they
have to say I think because I've always
had kind of a strong sense of self and I
tend to be pretty critical and push back
and say well what's what's your evidence
for that buddy
um
I haven't had any philosophers that did
that to me I will say and this is
something I've been meaning to write
about
there are quite a few people
who will be too uncritical in Reading uh
philosophers who are critical of certain
things so every once in a while you get
somebody who's like you know I read this
person and they said there's no such
thing as free will and now I feel really
bad because of that and uh you know and
you're like well who the hell ever told
you that they were right you know why
would you assume that just because some
philosopher has said something that it's
actually correct a good another good
example of this people are like I don't
know if I can buy into stoicism because
Nietzsche criticized it or Hagel
criticized it he'd be like well
how do you know that Nietzsche is right
or hegel's right about this this thing
so I think if you
you know if you are finding yourself
saying oh I can't read this person
anymore because they're depressing me
you want to think about why it is that
spending your time reading somebody
whose thoughts you don't have to accept
is bothering you so much I I do think
that there are a lot of people who waste
our time a bit you know expecting us to
read them but that's a different matter
so all right
um
let's see
Ellie says or Eli says are you a fan of
Merciful Fate or King Diamond nah I'm
not really into them
um I'll tell you who really was into
them though my uh my sister my younger
sister got really really into King
Diamond and I think it was in part I
mean both of us were into metal but I
think it was in part the uh sort of like
theatrical voice and stuff like that
um I'll say this I I have a grudging
respect for them but I don't really
listen to them much so
uh black prairie says what can be
philosophically said about cybernetic
augmentations on the human body any
works that focus on this aspect of
transhumanism I've been really into
cyberpunk stories if that helps
um I mean there's an entire cyborg
Manifesto by
um Donna haraway that was written quite
a while ago
and I think you know reading the the
sort of cyber punkish speculative
fiction is is good for thinking about
these things too so we're sort of like
the answer that I gave a bit earlier
where I were about the uh
extraterrestrials where I was saying
um you know we got philosophy and then
we've got speculative fiction and
there's a lot of great philosophy that's
going on in speculative fiction
um
you know the the idea of augmenting
ourselves with technology goes back a
long long ways and I would say that you
know the way to go with this is not to
look for stuff that's just specifically
about
you know implants or or stuff like that
but to think about philosophy of
Technology more broadly and the first
you know speculations about this are
already there in Plato and Aristotle
thinking about writing as a technology
and thinking about uh mechanical things
with with Aristotle but you know we move
forward into modern times and we have
you know very interesting discussions
all over the place like you know Maurice
meloponte talking about the blind person
using a cane and that the cane is
actually not just a tool but it extends
their perceptual sphere Dairy dye has a
lot of stuff about
um
how does he put a prosthesis you know
um and so there's a ton of things out
there and there's also stuff sort of
warning us like Heidegger's worries
about in Framing and the question
concerning technology could be applied
to to many of these these things that
would be done to our bodies to augment
ourselves so there's lots and lots of
interesting philosophy of technology
stuff out there that I think would be
very relevant to that
um you know transhumanism is an
interesting topic
because it there's different varieties
right there's almost like we're going to
worship the machines kind of stuff or
we're going to get you know
past our our Humanity uh the Ancients
the medievals the moderns are all wrong
about the human Essence we need to be
free of this
um there's there's the you know more
measured kind of well let's think about
where this is taking us maybe we've
always been changing ourselves uh in
important ways kind of stuff so it's not
as if there's just one single
transhumanism out there
[Music]
um
all right uh uh ridicule have you read
Henry George's progress in poverty I
haven't
um sounds kind of like an interesting
thing but I don't know if I've actually
read any Henry George
um stanislaw are you familiar with uh
wad wadless
TARTA kuich's works I'm not
unfortunately so nothing I can really
say about that
um
John I really loved your videos on
heraclitus do you have any favorite
Scholars interpreters or readers of the
pre-socratics particularly heraclitus
Parmenides anima annexamander and or
empedocles I don't I mean I I'm not a
secondary Works kind of person very much
um there's lots of interesting
discussions but we're always hampered by
the fact that what we're doing
is working off of fragments rather than
entire texts unfortunately even with
permanentes we only have portions of the
poem and on the fragments that we have
of heraclitus are from a much larger
lost work on nature that would you know
maybe someday we'll find a manuscript of
it that would be awesome so a lot of the
stuff that I see talking about this
tends to be kind of speculative and very
much like well it could mean this and
sometimes they jump into therefore it
does mean this
um I I do want to say though that there
are some really interesting discussions
of these ancient philosophers in people
that are coming later like Plato and
Aristotle and
um you know to a certain extent
diagonize Laertes there's lots of
references to them in other thinkers
especially those who are more eclectic
in their nature like Cicero or Plutarch
you know
but I I don't I don't have
um a lot of favorites among like
historians of philosophy so to speak
um
all right say it says good evening
Professor good evening to you it's noon
here uh or a little past dude
um Yorick is it reason oh is a good
question is it reasonable to try to get
an essay or paper published as a student
or does it practically require a PhD to
have a good shot at getting published
so I would say this first right off the
the bat
if the place that you want to publish it
and there are thousands of venues that
you can publish in
if they demand that you have a PhD then
they're not a good place to publish
because the good philosophy journals are
not going to be they're going to be
doing Blind review right so it doesn't
matter what your credentials are you
could be as we call them independent
Scholars who may or may not have a PhD
or a masters for that matter
um it could be that you just read a lot
of philosophy on your own and if they
really do have double-blind review then
that's not supposed to matter
and
um there's many people who publish
things without having Advanced degrees
that are that are quite good
there are also I'll say there are
journals that are specifically
devoted to publishing undergraduate
um or graduate student work
so you can easily Google those and find
them there's a there's a number of them
in philosophy sometimes uh other
journals too will have like a special
edition
uh where they're publishing graduate
students also at conferences which is
another way of getting your papers
workshopped many conferences will have
special panels or sessions just for
students undergraduate or graduate
students you know for example
if I remember right the Aristotle and
Aristotelian tradition conference that I
just went to uh last month had one panel
that was all graduate students and it's
pretty common you know so I published
some things as a graduate student and we
were actually encouraged to see if we
could do so
um so I would I would encourage you to
look around for places that look like a
good fit for the kind of stuff that you
want to do and you know another thing
you didn't ask about this but I would
also say this
um you know if you want to be publishing
in journals you should be reading
journals and you get a sense after a
while if you read enough that like oh
this would be a good journal for me or
this probably wouldn't be a good journal
for me to send stuff off to there
they're probably not going to be
receptive to the style or the topics or
you know the approach that that I'm
interested in taking here and there's a
lot of specialty journals you know so
for example I've published stuff on
Saint Anselm in the Saint Anselm journal
in
um uh I'm trying to I'm blanking on it
it's published by the uh Franciscan
University Steubenville but also in
cistercian studies quarterly and why
cistercians because their cistercians
are an offshoot of the benedictines
Anselm was a benedicta and you know Etc
et cetera so you know that's that's uh
that might be helpful for you but I I
would and the one other thing that I'll
say because I don't want to keep saying
yes one more thing
um
it can be discouraging sending your work
out
or anxiety provoking too and not getting
the response that you would like because
the response you want is people writing
back and saying holy [__] this is
awesome we want to publish your work
right
it doesn't always happen and
um you might get a revise and resubmit
in which case you'll get some feedback
which could be helpful or not helpful
um sometimes you'll just get like what
they call a desk rejection where it
doesn't even go to the reviewers and the
editor is like yeah we don't want this
this stuff
um
so you know be prepared for rejection
but don't allow the fact that one
journal and the editor and the referees
have said no to you there
be taken as well my stuff isn't any good
and nobody wants to to look at it or
read it because I can tell you that I
have sometimes
um submitted something to one place and
I got feedback and I was like this is
off base and then I submit it somewhere
else and they're like holy [__] this is
awesome you know we want to publish this
it's it's a real crap shoot you don't
you don't know or rather a black box
right because it's not totally up to
chance it's more like it's human
motivations that you don't fully
understand right so worth uh worth
keeping in mind but that's a great
question all right ADN let's philosophy
stuff
um favorite metal bands uh yeah I got a
lot of and I don't have a favorite
band right if you'd ask me in my uh teen
years and maybe even my 20s probably I
would have said Iron Maiden and they're
definitely up there in like the top five
still but
you know I love Motorhead and Judas
Priest
um Black Sabbath Deep Purple you know uh
Uriah Heap I would say I like almost as
much as though those two and I consider
Uriah Heap some very important curly
metal too
um
you know I like the band there's quite a
few new wave of British heavy metal
bands that I really like so tank who are
kind of similar to Motorhead Raven Girls
School uh Tokyo blade you know I I wish
they had done better same with tigers
pantang
um
and you know there's some more recent
bands I mean I also like rat they're
they're in my that my top group there's
some like International bands like Dio
where he drew on Talent from all over
the place and of course the precursor
rainbow where Richie Blackmore kind of
apprenticed Ronnie James Dio
um there's some you know more recent
bands that I I really like
um Orchid for example I kind of wish
that they'd they'd stayed together and
didn't stop producing albums because
they're my favorite Doom metal band
um so there's lots and lots of bands
that I really like and I'll mention too
that I've gotten to see some pretty good
bands lately including and I'll I'll
give a shout out here to a band that
they were you know sort of like girls
school and all woman band uh back in the
1980s Vixen and in the 1980s they were
okay they weren't great but they were
good and they were a little bit on the
softer side uh we saw them at Summerfest
and I said we me and my child Kat who's
also a metal head and uh they were
pretty amazing now that's because they
only have one original member left the
drummer
um the guitarist who started with them
in 2017
um she also plays in a guns and Rose
Rose's tribute band Paradise Kitty she's
really solid they have a new bassist who
was essentially hand-picked by the
previous bassist to take over for her
some Brazilian uh Yulia I forget her
last name and she is just incredible and
a great singer sort of like Juan
croacher with rat you know playing bass
and also singing and then the new the
new singer is uh you know somebody
probably a bit older than me but she's
really got the pipes and she's a great
front woman and so there's sometimes
bands that started out maybe not quite
so strong but they were they upgraded as
they went along right so
all right uh Mark says uh why is Cicero
so awesome I reread his Republican laws
recently great text how would you
compare his use of the dialogue format
to Plato any other writers you think
wrote great dialogues okay so a lot of
things there
um
let's start with the dialogue I I don't
think that Cicero's dialogues are as
dialogue
as our Plato's I think sometimes Cicero
uses the the dialogue format
more as a rhetorical device unless as
something
essential to what he's doing but his his
dialogues are in fact genuine dialogues
as opposed to some other writers where
um and Plato sometimes does this where
there's log sections where Socrates is
like and let me explain this to you
doesn't it seem like this and they're
like oh yes Socrates go on you know
um
why is Cicero so great so
I think it has to do with a couple
factors
one is
um you know Cicero was able to study
with
great representatives of all the major
philosophies that were around at his
time and be you know he could sort of
assimilate them he had time to think
about them and he's not writing most of
his stuff as a young man he's writing it
much later on
you know when he's uh no longer able to
be involved with politics because
Caesar's faction has has won he's also
writing uh quite a few of his works as a
consolation for himself after the death
of the person he was probably closest to
his daughter uh
Ilia I'm I'm maybe having a senior
moment here myself
um and the other thing that's important
to remember about Cicero and you see
this in the prefaces to a lot of his
texts
is that
um he had a project
and his project was to take philosophy
from Greek the language and put it into
a Roman Latin format to demonstrate that
philosophy could in fact be done in
Latin and I want to say that there's
something about having like a big
project that really brings out the best
in certain philosophers
so you know like maybe Plato's project
originally was to sort of memorialize
his great teacher's Socrates and then it
morphed into something more you know
um Aristotle's project was sort of like
to contribute to and understand all
these different fields of phenomena and
knowledge right so having a big project
like that can often be quite quite
helpful
now other writers who wrote great
dialogues well Augustine is a prime
example right
Augustine has some pretty excellent
dialogues and uh so does Anselm of
Canterbury you could think of boethius's
uh
consolation of philosophy is a dialogue
too right I mean it's it's written in
kind of a novel format but it's it's
it's a dialogue between boethius and
Lady philosophy who shows up and says
why so glum my friend
uh we could go on further I mean you
know hume's dialogues concerning natural
religion brilliant uh and he uses a sort
of technique that he's getting from
Cicero in uh Cicero's Dialogue on the
nature of the Gods right which is to
have the characters kind of spiral off
against each other and to endorse none
of their positive statements but all the
negative conclusions
um and you know it goes on down to the
present there are still philosophers
writing in dialogue format today which I
think is is quite good so yeah some good
questions there
um
let's see what else we have oh
mondavarius what's the best Library
you've ever visited that is an
interesting question
so
I don't usually go and like visit
libraries unless I'm actually going to
use them and I will talk about a couple
libraries
so
the ones that I've used the most from my
own research
and and found the best
one of them is probably no longer as
good anymore
and that was the Southern Illinois
University at Carbondale
Morris Library
which was at that time just excellent uh
and it set the standard for me because
you know Southern Illinois University
Carbondale is kind of a low tier it's
got a graduate school it's got a law
school right but it's not considered to
be like a great school or anything like
that but they had just an amazing
Library you know so much resources
um really quite uh extensive I
understand there have been a lot of cuts
to the library since then which is
unfortunate and so I just sort of took
it for granted that well if things are
this good at Carbondale they must be
this good everywhere which is definitely
not the case
another Library where I did a lot of
research is Notre Dame universities
hessberg Library which is this giant
Tower you may have seen pictures of it
if you Google Touchdown Jesus uh you
will get to see a picture of the hesper
Tower and why is it called Touchdown
Jesus because it's got a big Mosaic of
Jesus with his arms up like this which
is the signal in football for a
touchdown you know so
um and that plays holy crap did they
have amazing Holdings I I did a lot of
the research for my book reason
fulfilled by Revelation the 1930 30s
Christian philosophy debates in France
at that place as well and then um
another smaller library but one that I
have a particular attachment to and I
found to be quite quite a good place was
um Saint Anselm colleges Geisel Library
which has the Saint Anselm collection so
I did two summer research fellowships
very
um fortunately funded by the
um
Institute for Saint Anselm studies there
uh over the years and I use their
resources and it was uh really awesome
and the people there are really great
too I would like to point out too though
that here in Milwaukee our Central
Library our Public Library the central
one is an amazing place it's beautiful
outside and it's beautiful insight as
well and I have done so I've spent so
much time there over the years I started
going there when I was in high school
and we would have to drive in and do
research there and now it's just blocks
away I actually have some books on on
hold there that I have to go get on
Monday because I won't be able to go
today
and they have in addition to the entire
library and what they've got they've got
four basement levels all of which are
filled with what they call Storage tiers
and a storage here the books that they
you can get they'll bring them up for
you and you just have to request them so
four stories underground with the same
footprint as the library as far as I
understand they also have some really
cool stuff in their special collections
including a lot of Wisconsin yeah you
know Arkham house Publications uh those
sorts of things so those are some of my
favorite libraries I don't know what
would count as the best you know it's
probably we have to decide what the
criteria for that are
all right
um shalu Priya says how to deal with the
predicament of irreversibility in terms
of harsh deeds in the past that can't be
undone but feed on the conscience as we
go on with time becoming painfully
self-conscious as we go on okay so
um I mean everything's irreversible in
that sense Good Deeds bad Deeds right
um
things that we do in general because
time moves in One Direction are
irreversible but you know if you've done
wrong to somebody you can try to make
amends you can try to also think about
the person that you are and try to be
become a better person and improve
yourself and teach other people about
stuff so I I think that um
it's not irreversibility it's dealing
with the fact that you are now conscious
of like you did something wrong and
you're you're not happy with yourself
over the effects of it
um sometimes you can't fix the original
situation but maybe you can as we say
Pay It Forward by helping somebody else
who you should have helped in the past
or you know contributing to I mean let's
say you were mean to a certain kind of
people maybe you can be good to the that
kind of people going forward in the
future I think back to
all the different ways in which I was
messed up in the past sometimes and I
haven't totally overcome all these
either and you know some of the people
that I was mean to or even animals that
that I was I was mean to or thoughtless
to
um could I have done better yes uh
they're gone
can I do better in the presence yeah uh
that that's a possibility so maybe
that'll help
all right uh Gus uh maybe a basic
question but what does nature mean by
Will To Power yeah that is a basic
question but it's a really important
basic question now isn't it because
that's Central to Nietzsche's thought
so the will to power takes a lot of
different forms and each of thinks that
almost everything has some manifestation
of this I mean it obviously gets much
more complex as we move up into
conscious beings and those that have
societies and all that and the idea is
that
you have a will and you know what that
will is by what it does so you by virtue
of having a will being a living thing
you attempt to impose yourself on other
things and other things are doing that
to you and you can push back against it
you can incorporate them into yourself
but ultimately
you know you're you're this will to
power that wants to have more life and
uh to have you know the opportunity to
expend itself to do things to determine
things
and you do so in a context of other
Wills to power which you may dominate or
you may exploit and then you may be
dominated or exploited in turn as well
and even your body and your uh the
things that come out of your body from
each other the notion of a soul or a
spirit
those are all sort of like little Wills
that get unified or at least integrated
by a greater will that is you and so
that's that's maybe a thumbnail sketch
of the will to power
power all right
um let's see here
just skipped a little bit
um
foreign
Christopher asked do you agree with
hegel's philosophy if not what do you
disagree with I mean I agree with
hegel's philosophy and some things and I
disagree with him and other things and
obviously one of the most important
areas of disagreement is thinking that
history didn't end in you know 1807 or
1816 or pick whatever else date you want
I also think that Hegel despite his
criticisms of formalism is often rather
to formalistic himself and his
Arrangements of stuff
um and his understandings of things I
think he's obviously wrong in in saying
in the history of philosophy that none
of us could be stoics or epicureans or
anything else in the present
um I think that you know he's he there's
a lot of things where he says things and
you're like yeah that's not right I get
what he's saying I get why he's saying
it but um here's where I think he's he's
actually got things wrong you know I
think he can often be a little bit too
rigid and one-sided which is interesting
because these are things that he accuses
others of in his takes on
um how Consciousness has developed you
know but I think that there's a lot of
really good stuff to pull out of Hegel
you know one of the things one of the
parts of the phenomenology that I
probably like the best
is buried deep in the spirit section and
it's his analysis of moral action and
how complicated and many factored it is
and that it's so difficult to do a
purely good thing you know
um and here and he explains why right
and leads you through it so those are
some cool things
um
so this is cool black prairie has
something responding to Yorick and says
that they're an undergrad they've gotten
two of their essays published in two
different journals from their University
that's really awesome to read
um
you know as I mentioned there are
undergraduate journals but there's
nothing that keeps like an undergrad or
a graduate student from sending out
their work to uh
just the regular journal and seeing if
somebody will go for it right
uh edemont I'm just starting Plato in
your recent video on depression you talk
about how Plato helped you out can you
tell me which parts
yeah I would say that you know thinking
about the arrangement of the Soul was
useful
um interestingly Plato himself doesn't
talk about sadness or depression very
much but
a lot of later thinkers
used Plato's tripartite conception of
the Soul including a lot of Christian
thinkers
and sadness or tristia
is Lupe actually in Greek pain more
broadly is one of the eight Capital
vices for example in John Cassian where
does that occur it occurs in the same
part of the soul that we get angry with
the thumos
and so you know thinking about what
later platonus did with that is is is
quite helpful I would also say too you
know this is not something unique to
Plato this is kind of a virtue ethics
thing in general
if you want to be able to regulate your
life well and not give in to you know
sadness sorrow depression or the other
things that often accompany irritability
anger uh anxiety
then figuring out how to unscrew
yourself up because you start out
screwed up
uh can be extraordinary extraordinarily
helpful and the other thing that's
important too is you know
Plato and again this is something that
you see in all the virtue ethics
traditions
a lot of the troubles that we have
are caused by mistakes on a cognitive
level
and this is something that you see
worked out in Plato's dialogues over and
over again you know you think that death
is a bad thing why do you think it's a
bad thing let's evaluate let's think
this through do we really know enough
about death to say that it is the
catastrophe that we believe it to be I
mean Plato's got Socrates talking about
these sorts of things you know so I
think that that might be helpful
uh August says I felt with my lack of
formal philosophy training that whenever
I would go write something or read
something I always confront the
questions have I read this correctly are
there tools for this
um
I mean it should get better over time
right and with multiple reads
you do have to ask yourself what are the
standards that you're trying to
impose upon yourself or question
yourself about what what what
constitutes a correct reading
and there's probably multiple levels to
this like if you read Plato's apology
and and somebody asks you what's that
book about and you're like well Socrates
is is thinking about hot dogs and how
much he really loves hot dogs and that
he should go get a get a hot dog from
the vendor in the park obviously that's
a wrong reading right and that's like a
totally wrong reading uh other than the
fact that it's got a guy named Socrates
in it
um but then you know getting to well I
read it this time in the time before I
didn't quite realize what Socrates was
talking about with the underworld and
being able to question Achilles and you
know all these other people and them not
being able to kill him for that and then
thinking about the fact that one of the
implications of this is that Socrates is
going to be doing his constant
questioning of people down in Hades and
he's probably going to be pissing off
the Dead who then can't kill him
um okay that might not be something that
you get the first time you read it or
the second time or the third time and
are you are you
wrong in this
um are you incorrect In not noting that
maybe not because that's
kind of a sideline I mean figuring out
who so here's a good example
um when I teach the apology to my
undergrad students I always give them an
assignment explain who the old accusers
are and why they're upset with Socrates
and why Socrates is more afraid of them
than the new accusers and a lot of the
students get it right you know
and then some students will be like
melatus and anetus are the old accusers
and you're like well that's wrong okay
so you know those are those sort of
lower level
um incorrect things right
um but you know if you read through the
old accusers and the first couple times
you don't notice that Socrates does
doesn't say that they don't know
anything
The Poets don't know what they're doing
the politicians don't know what they're
doing he doesn't explain about the
writers although he says that they're
being represented but the craftspeople
do know something right the problem is
that they think that because they know
something in their craft they know other
things so you know
um being able to tell you know at these
different levels what you're getting
right and what you're maybe missing or
getting wrong about it that's that's
important and how do you check this well
there isn't any recipe for that
um but you can compare your reading with
other people's readings right this is
where having classes and resources and
stuff like that can be very helpful I'd
say
all right
um
let's see here say it says can you talk
a bit about the best way to get the
general public interested in theory and
philosophy especially now in the student
culture so apathetically ironic a
concern president of my Uni's philosophy
Club so
um there isn't any
like automatic way to get the general
public interested in stuff and
oftentimes when you do get the general
public interest that in philosophy stuff
they manage to like do it in a
wrong-headed and superficial way so for
example you know if macron
um uh the Pres you know president of
France uh quotes Hegel suddenly Hegel
gets mentioned in the you know French
national newspapers then it goes
worldwide and people are like see
there's a politician who cares about
Hegel but does macrame actually
understand Hale probably not I mean I I
don't know the guy but it's probably
debatable and then all the people will
weigh in with crap about oh Hegel this
Hegel that and you know reporters will
get on it and and screw it up typically
right uh I mean we see this every year
when we try to get reporters interested
in uh stoicon and the stoicon x's and
stoic week and many of them really muff
it up and misquote us and stuff like
that so uh
I guess what I'm saying is if you do
want to try to get the public interested
in philosophy put your bar really really
low right and have have low expectations
be ready to like try to address them and
you know instead of like getting ticked
off with them you stupid idiots you you
got Plato wrong or you got Descartes
wrong you know uh be there as a resource
to explain to them
um I think that you can there's a lot of
things that we can call like uh doorways
or gateway drugs or whatever to get
people interested in philosophy well so
let's take dick hard for example
um
everybody knows I think therefore I am
and there's all sorts of memes out there
about it and then you could say well
what is thinking what what counts as
thinking
and as it turns out
um Descartes gives you a list of that in
meditations too
where he says what is it to be a
thinking thing a thing that that affirms
denies Wills Wills against doubts
um senses feels all these sorts of
things now now you've opened up the
possibility
for conversations to happen so this is
exactly the sort of thing you could do
you know with your philosophy Club I
think that would be great and there's
like you open the doors you get
discussions going and you keep coming
back to the text not in sort of uh well
you must have read the text kind of way
but sort of like hey
um so-and-so has already talked about
this wouldn't it be cool if we read this
short passage and then we thought about
this and by the way if you want to know
more about Descartes here's the books
that he wrote and you know you can check
these out they're available at the
University library or at the bookstore
so
I guess in part what I'm saying is you
know give them kind of bite-sized chunks
and try to make it stuff that people
would be curious about or
are worried by you know
um
so you know Descartes is a good good
person to start with I mean another
interesting thing you could do with
Descartes
um
people are really interested in
artificial intelligence right now
um and the capacity for machines to
mimic us human beings so he talks about
that in discourse uh section five
and he lays out some criteria for how we
can tell the difference between a human
being that has a mind and a machine that
doesn't have a mind but tries to imitate
a human being
that could be I mean that would be a big
draw right so and you know
um Sayed I'd say too you know you can
find my email on the uh uh about page
for my um channel so it's like for
business inquiries
um if you've got a philosophy club and
this goes for anybody else who's out
there like doing public philosophy and
that that's what Syed is talking about
doing public philosophy Philosophy for
the public
um and you got a club and you want to um
Kick around an idea or two go ahead and
email me about it you know
um I'm happy to uh see people doing that
all right Eli a what ideas concepts of
Jacques Lacon are you critical of if any
I mean less an idea and more like his
overall style laca is deliberately an
obscure writer and I think he um didn't
do himself any favors by by doing that
um I you know one thing I do like about
Lecom Freud gets a lot of flack for the
Oedipus complex and I think the Oedipus
complex is probably you know I mean
maybe there are some people out there
who it does fit but it's definitely not
the blueprint for Humanity lacan
recognizes that and he he tells you that
at different points in his seminars
right
um that it's just one of many different
configurations of the symbolic that's
possible and I'll mention another thing
too I think there's things that like
laka put out there and then people turn
they reified into ideas like the mirror
stage right the mirror stage is not an
explanation of people in general it's
something that you progress through and
you leave behind Oedipus complex too by
the way if you have it is something that
you're supposed to actually like work
through and leave behind not the general
blueprint for human nature or something
like that I think there's a lot of cases
where laka is drawing on stuff that he's
read and he's being a little bit too
precious with it and and um trying to
get so much mileage out of it he was
also very defensive when it comes to
other
psychoanalysts psychotherapists
psychologists
um and perhaps a little bit too
dismissive of other people's work uh at
points so you know that that's probably
enough there uh e Derman says you're not
you said you're not a stoic and you're
more of an Eclectic can you tell me what
your influences are when it comes to how
you handle life I mean you know I draw
heavily on the stoics just like Cicero
did uh the Aristotelian tradition the
platonist tradition even the epicureans
a lot of uh Christian thinkers
particularly early Christian thinkers
who were engaged with all of those
schools you know the existentialists uh
dialectical philosophers like Hegel
um all of these sorts of things play a
role for for me you know so
um
important uh uh critical thinkers like
Mary Wollstonecraft you know more recent
feminist thinkers other anti-racist
thinkers play a role in my in my
approach to things you know
um I you know but the stoics are are
important and I will say this I probably
know more and use more of stoicism than
many of the people out there who call
themselves stoics not the high level
ones but all the beginners because
there's too many people that are like I
want to be on team X
and we don't really need to be on teams
um as a matter of fact Matthew sharp
recently published a great piece about
why this is such a problem in his
um medium publication so worth checking
out
all right Galen says have you got any
individuals from the desert fathers or
maybe the Phila Khalia you found helpful
in areas of philosophy that you work and
dealing with anger
um yeah and I don't worry about the
desert Fathers as such that was just
like a nice designation that people lump
together for you know putting things
into a book I mean what is John Cassian
what are who are his conferences with
those guys out in the desert in Egypt
right
so um John Cassian is like one major
resource and so is um
uh evagrius ponticus right so those are
quite important
um Maximus the Confessor is somebody
pretty interesting well worth checking
out from the Philo Kalia there's all
sorts of people but I mean Cassian and
ponticus are probably the ones I'm
drawing on the most
uh Theo Rose could you recommend
philosophers who discuss that their
intrinsic schemas structures in our
minds that determine the way we can
think about or comprehend reality
yeah Manuel Kant right
I mean what do you think the first
critique and the prologomina uh are
touching on when they talk about
categories of the understanding or
concepts of the pure understanding
that's that's that right
um Rene Descartes thinks that the
concept of Truth is in our mind and that
we have all sorts of other innate ideas
in the great treasure Houser thesaurus
of our mind this is this is a pretty
Common Place sort of thing all the way
down to those who want to say linguistic
structures are you know fundamental and
basic to us in the 20th century so but
you know a lot of these things
turn out to be
um not so
cut and dried as the theorists make them
out to be
uh oh here's a good question from Wes
wood uh what did you like and what did
you dislike about your philosophy
classes when you were in college
so when I was in college as opposed to
graduate school I only had two
philosophy professors but I got to read
some philosophy in other classes
and both of my professors were really
near retirement age and probably should
have retired they weren't good teachers
at all the one was constantly scheduling
his classes at eight and nine in the
morning and he was not a morning person
and I even asked him about why he did
that and he said so I can get my
important work done later in the day
when I'm actually awake
and uh I I had like ethics with him and
intro and
um
logic and I know I had a couple other
classes with the guy
um and then he ended up like becoming
the dean after a while and kind of you
know he was also busy with this history
project that he had going on so he
didn't really care much about about
philosophy and he let me do what I
wanted to do you know and then we had
the other guy who did the history of
philosophy stuff took ancient and
medieval with him modern contemporary
and here here's this will give you an
idea of what contemporary philosophy was
right they didn't know anything about
contemporary analytic philosophy I think
the latest thinker that we read
was Ryle
and this is in the 1990s you know so
they just hadn't kept up on the
literature
and they thought that process philosophy
was still a important area of philosophy
existentialism was really big they
didn't know much about like critical
philosophy or you know let alone like
you know contemporary philosophy of
language and so their classes were you
know very old school and
um
in some respects not very challenging or
interesting I did a lot on my own as an
undergraduate no I was also partying a
lot and getting you know being in
relationships and playing in bands so I
had plenty of stuff to keep me busy
perfect but I I didn't get any real like
formation or structure to my my
education
that said that probably benefited me
I've seen a lot of people who went to
schools where they had a lot of
structure and they come out of it with
this idea that they now know where
everything fits in in the history of
philosophy and they usually have it
wrong right so you know there is no like
ideal
teaching and learning situation
uh guy can't find a good answer online
what does Hegel really mean by Spirit
how conveyed Concepts like the age or
the world have spirits well the age of
the world aren't Concepts they're
realities right and
um spirit is uh you know if you want to
translate it as the interplay between
Consciousness self-consciousness and
history and culture that might work as
well right there's all sorts of spirits
that are all part of world spirits and
World Spirit unfolds itself and develops
itself and it does so differently in
different ages I mean this is this is
all easy to find stuff I mean I I don't
think that you can't find a good answer
online I think you probably haven't dug
very much
um because there's lots and lots of
discussions of of what spirit means
Massacre as a Catholic what is your view
on the historicity or historic
historical accuracy of the Bible
including the New Testament do you care
about historical variation potential
inaccuracies why or why not I don't care
an awful lot about them like I don't I'm
not worried about whether Jonah was
swallowed by a whale or something like
that
um and I don't know why you bring up
being Catholic because the Catholic
church has been pretty clear about this
for at least a century that a lot of
these stories are stories you know
they're not meant to be taken completely
literally you know
um
I mean I I remember I for I'm forgetting
which encyclical it's in but John Paul
had an interesting remark about the Cain
and Abel story where he's like what
matters in this story is not whether
there was a cane or Abel or whether
these were the only two other humans
besides Adam and Eve at the time what
matters is that the first death is a
murder and we need to think about that
right when it comes to the gospels I
have no reason to think that you know
it's all mythology or some crazy
[__] like like that that you always
got to ask with people who are like I'm
gonna debunk what's their motive what
are they getting out of that you know
um and there's some things that are more
important than others I mean the
teaching I come back to this every time
that people ask me about Christianity if
you claim to care about this Jesus guy
and want to follow him then you got to
re read or reread the Sermon on the
Mount and the other places where he's
teaching and you follow that stuff right
does it matter like how many Loaves and
Fishes there were that's not what the
point of the story is right the point is
to make us think about the nature of
abundance right or why it's important to
feed a crowd or why Jesus Takes pity on
them you know and coming back to The
Sermon on the Mount if you can't
Implement those teachings then all the
other stuff is kind of
besides the point you know so that's my
view on it
uh Solomon Salvador thoughts on uh
Michael De biron
um
so I don't know a Michael to be run I
know a Maine to be run
um and I've read a little bit of this
stuff but it's been a long time he's an
interesting
philosopher who
um French people often tend to read in
reference but nobody else really does as
a matter of fact marila Ponte has a
great set of lectures that he gave on
the unity of the soul and the body in
Descartes men to be RAM and bergson
which kind of shows you where he fits in
but you know
uh I'll be Pratap how to overcome
stuttering or stammering I don't know I
mean it's not an area of my work there's
plenty of people out there I think that
you could consult you know that might
help you out with that
um Michael says my past is like a Book
of Unwritten chapters with no text or
story absolute social isolation all of
high school college mid-20s how can I
know
how I want to contribute value to life
with no history well you don't have no
history you're being hyperbolic there
you have a history the history is of
disengagement and isolation right and I
would say uh you know look at other
people who have been similarly isolated
and see if they provide you with any
models you know
um but
maybe you don't want to contribute value
you need to think that out too
um Emil durkheim would love to hear more
about you would love to hear you expand
on your idea of Divine Providence of the
world how does science generally tend to
operate within it
I mean
wouldn't if you believe in Divine
Providence wouldn't the development of
the Sciences also be part of that Divine
Providence
um you know think about Anton and Anton
and certiage the great 20th century
Thomas French writer who had no problem
in some of his books I'm not sure if
they've been translated into English
talking about how uh the theory of
evolution isn't really a a major concern
because if you believe in a providential
ordering of the universe why the hell
wouldn't God use Evolution as a tool you
know
um
William
any thoughts on how to read some
philosophy of History
find a philosophy of history book and
read it
there's plenty of authors out there I
think one of the ones that's you know
kind of pedestrian but isn't going to
steer you wrong
um Friedrich hobblestone you know
there's plenty of history of philosophy
stuff you can read
um
let's see here
malvika says since getting into
philosophy I find myself doubting all
that I have read spent a month reading
up on the best way to read dad thinks
I'm going crazy did this ever happen to
you okay so that's that's actually a
good concern
um this is something that does happen
to people when they start studying
philosophy sometimes it just happens by
reading Descartes and going through
meditations one and two and being like
holy crap I don't actually know anything
for sure this is terrible right and I've
known people who who had that sort of
existential crisis
and you know there's the like reading a
bunch of different people and being like
I don't know which which of these are
correct anymore I mean there's a remedy
for that though which is continuing on
and studying more philosophy and
lowering the bar for what you need in
order to believe that somebody
might have things at least halfway right
Epictetus talking about the beginning of
philosophy disagrees with Plato and
Aristotle who want to say it's in
something like Wonder or awe and
Epictetus says no it's in seeing the
differences of viewpoint between human
beings about important stuff and then
wondering are any of these actually
correct and then trying to figure it out
so there's philosophers who themselves
have expressed these sorts of problems
Rene Descartes this is I mean this is if
you read his discourse uh on method he
says that it's because there were so
many things that I thought were right
that it turned out not to be so and then
there's like a diversity of opinion that
made me worry about whether I could
actually arrive at truth or not
um you're not alone in that right so I
guess to your dad you could say hey
there's other big name philosophers
who've run into this problem before in
the past too right
okay Justin says being so well read with
so many philosophers in their works
what are some major takeaways that we
can apply to our lives not in a
day-to-day way but more so what we ought
to be doing or working toward
so I'll say I'm not that well read I
don't think anybody is that well read I
did a
quick takes about this a while back
about the concern about being well read
it's impossible to be truly well read in
in this time you know
um but okay so major takeaways not in a
day-to-day way but more what we ought to
be doing or working towards so you know
this is a preoccupation in ancient
philosophy and also in a lot of medieval
and modern philosophy
how should I be orienting my life
there's lots of potential paths to take
and you know many of them seem quite
attractive
how should I
um
how should I decide are there any
criteria or is it just like a crap shoot
you know or should I just try a bunch of
different things out right that that's a
really important topic isn't it and we
see this discussed by Plato by Aristotle
buy the stoics buy Cicero buy boethius
by Augustine and we can keep going
forward right
um and I think another big question I
actually like this quite a bit
um what are the big questions that I
should be concerned with
um that kind of put other questions into
place
what kind of person do I want to be and
what do I have to do
to move from the person who I discover
myself to be now to being that kind of
person and why do I why do I want to
become that kind of person you know it's
for example somebody could have
um an Awakening and they're like I
thought I just wanted to make a ton of
money and why did I want to do that so I
could have a nice secure lifestyle for
my family that I want to have and enjoy
myself I don't want to hurt anybody in
the process I don't want to cheat lie
steal but I want to work hard and maybe
build a business or a career and have
this fulfilling life and then at a
certain point they're like
well
that might not make me happy
you know I see other people doing this
and then they have midlife crises
um what is life really about you know
that's that's a really great question
ask yourself so I think that's that is a
good question to ask
uh Leslie says Christ says judge no one
in the first half of John he discusses
not judging others and death Blondell
refers to this Duty seeming to incur we
offer mercy and patience and beatitude
thoughts yeah he's not saying don't make
any judgments he's he's saying don't
judge other people you know unless you
want to be judged if you're content
being judged go ahead and be judged
right and you do have to make judgments
um everybody in moral philosophy
including Blondell knows that the
question is whether you're going to make
them in a good way it's not as if
judgment and charity are incompatible
with each other this is a classic
problem you know I've written quite a
few things on Anselm and how ansem
reconciles Divine Justice which involves
judging with divine mercy so you don't
want to go too far in the let's not
judge at all uh Direction because that's
a mistake too
uh all right men a wild Dr Sadler live
stream has appeared would you be willing
to make or film a course on logic would
love to see it
um I mean I I did those things on
critical thinking years and years ago
with Fayetteville State that are out
there there's also somebody out there
who's done a ton of great stuff her name
is Dr logic so I'm not sure why I would
need to replicate what other people are
already doing well when there's so much
other work for me to be doing you know
all right
um
Galen bornster says I think I remember
that Saint Anselm Fellowship did you
video document your your week there
I did with the second one not with the
first one
um and yeah it's you can find them in my
uh Sadler's stories uh playlist
uh Thomas Gerard says have you said any
work in hermeneutics gotimer at Alia do
you find it interesting what value do
you find in studying it yeah I've uh
studied quite a few people that are
considered to be part of the
hermeneutics thing I mean Heidegger's is
one of the key people
um I've read gotimer's truth and Method
and some of his other works you know
like his stuff on Plato's dialogues
um and you know gotimer is okay he's
kind of uh long-winded I would say
somebody else in the hermit hermeneutics
um broad movement that I like quite a
bit is Paul recor
so you know and I like hermeneutics
stress on making sense out of texts and
that we never get away from
interpretation where we always have to
take account of ourselves as doing that
uh ridicule do you remember how old you
were when you read your first platonic
dialogue and which one it was
so I I don't know which one it was
um
we didn't read Plato an intro to
philosophy because we had an intro to
philosophy textbook
and I think the first platonic dialogue
I probably read would have been in my
ancient philosophy class
when I was a sophomore in college so I
probably would have been
21.
at that time
and
I'm guessing it probably was the apology
you know
but that's what or maybe the Youth of
fro I don't know I mean it's been such a
long time
uh that would have been
1991. it's a more than
30 years ago
um do you recommend to go and get a
Philosophy degree up to a PhD I mean if
you want to sure I mean recommend for
what uh there isn't any blanket
recommendation for that
uh Elijah how can blown Dell's writing
on sacraments and beatitude make
beatitude out of a deprived past they
require virtue out of Personality
disordered and brain damage who aren't
vicious but animalistic you're blurring
together a lot of stuff there there
isn't there isn't an easy answer for
that
um
and I wouldn't focus on blondell's
writings on sacraments I would focus on
blondell's you know philosophical Works
um rather than
stuff that's like
offshoots or his recently translated uh
what is that the exigencies of
Christianity or something like that
uh Mr McGee do you believe we went to
the moon yep uh the year before I was
born
uh Patrick what general advice and
insights can you give somebody who's
about to start a math philosophy double
major especially with regards to having
grad school as a future goal
um you know just here's the advice I'd
give you just like you know take
whatever you can get don't worry about
like having to like have a big you know
philosophy of life or system or anything
like that at this time when you're an
undergrad your your job is to learn you
know and to assimilate and you don't
have to worry about like getting
everything into its proper place at this
time oh here's a great question from
kolamus
have you ever lost interest in
philosophy or felt worried that you had
do you have any suggestions for
returning to that yeah I have
um I went through a kind of malaise like
that
in graduate school at a certain point
and I even went to Rick Williams my
Classics Professor about that and you
may have heard me tell this story before
but it could be useful for others so I
got myself stuck into this line of
thinking uh well what's the point to all
of this you know it's like I'm learning
this stuff so that I can comment on it
and teach about it to other people and
I'm basically I'm not going to come up
with anything you know really original
of my own maybe I'll put together some
interesting stuff from other people but
what's what's ultimately the point and
it's you know it's this feeling of
sort of
existential as sarc called it nausea
right Nietzsche actually uses that word
too and we're being aware of the the
nature of Life a kind of nihilism right
and Rick Williams said
here's the best I can give you
um
my studies and he's the guy who I
studied Plato with uh we read the
Symposium together over an entire
semester in Greek
um he said I'm a guy who's sitting at a
fire I didn't start the fire and I don't
have to go and start a new fire of my
own we've got a fire right here
and I do have a job my job is to keep
tending to this fire and putting logs
into it and not letting the fire go out
that's my like studying my my discipline
and all that and if somebody wants to
come sit by the fire with me that's cool
if not
that's cool too because it's a
worthwhile fire
and if somebody else wants to come after
me and take over my job of tending to
the fire that's great if not I'll just
keep tending the fire
and that helped me somehow
um and he said well that doesn't apply
exactly well it doesn't have to it's a
story right
and at a certain point you'll either
come back to it or you won't
and you can't really force it and you
shouldn't force it
I think if you've if you've got if
you've been studying philosophy with
with colomos I know that that he has
um
it's got its hooks in you and sooner or
later
it'll play out some line and it'll pull
you back
and you'll feel happy when that happens
or maybe vexed right but it'll it'll
happen and then you start up again and
it's sort of like
um you know getting tired of hanging out
with some of your friends and you go and
do your own thing for a while
and then later on you realize I want to
hang out with them and you go and catch
up with them that's that's what it's
going to be like so it it happens to a
lot of us I think and it happens not
just with philosophy but musicians with
playing music it happens to athletes who
become tired of their workouts people
get tired of each other this is a common
thing because you know human beings are
creatures that are not like robots where
they're just doing their one thing so
all right uh vegan sports bar a friend
of mine thinks we'll eventually develop
an AI that can handle all human Affairs
and ensure World Peace this seems to me
a dehumanized and extremely dangerous
idea thoughts well I mean I doubt
that'll happen if it does happen
um handle all human Affairs
um I mean I doubt that would ever be the
case humans will always be monkeying
around with things so I don't I'm not so
worried about the dehumanizing thing I'm
I'm more worried about crazy humans who
think that AI is doing more than it's
actually doing and therefore like put
their stamp on other people and control
other people
um I mean if there was an AI that could
take over a lot of the mundane tasks
that we do and help out with things and
actually engage us as human beings that
would be pretty cool wouldn't it I mean
that would be sort of like iron banks uh
culture Series where they live this
post-scarcity future with you know
trillions and trillions of human beings
and very intelligent AIS and everybody's
got a pretty good existence and then if
you want a little excitement well you go
out to the uh I forget exactly what he
called the people like special services
or the frontier or something like that
the odds of that happening are pretty
low I mean we human beings don't even
really understand our own societies
adequately how the hell is an AI which I
mean frankly the AIS that are out there
they're not actually the the eye is a
big metaphor they're not intelligent
they're not even remotely close to it
you know
um so I I'm not really concerned about
that
um
allionic I think I remember you saying
you wanted to be a creative writer do
you still write poetry and or fiction
haven't written any fiction for a long
time I wrote my wife Hassan it a while
back uh but I don't write a lot of
poetry but I should start again I mean I
do write creative nonfiction from time
to time
um
so
it's it's it's something I haven't given
much thought or time to
um an ordered whole do you have a
structured routine to reread important
Works how do you approach re-reading
works I don't have anything I just
reread them you know a lot of times I'm
rereading them it's because I want to do
a video series or a client wants me to
help them with tutorials or something
like that there's no routine that I've
got and even if I did have a routine it
might not be useful for for you
oh this is a good one from Jeff Sullivan
platonic dialogue you've changed your
mind on the most since beginning to
study philosophy
so yeah that's a tough one
I would say
um
the Republic
because you know when I first read it I
think I did like buy into this is a
blueprint for the perfect Society
um laid out by by Plato
and you know the thracimicus thing is
just sort of stage setting and you know
the really important thing is the ideal
city that's being laid out
and my mind has changed because first of
all it's not the ideal city it's the
second best City
they never actually lay out the ideal
city in a detail because
um
Socrates sets out a very rudimentary
ideal city and then glaucon and
adamantis are like these people don't
have pickles you know they don't have
sauces for their meat and stuff like
that they're laying on beds of straw you
know and then Socrates is like oh I get
it you don't want the best city you want
a luxurious City let's see if we can
make that work
but I don't really think I think that's
only one part of what's going on with
the Republic I think all the other parts
matter I think there is a psychology
there that's really important I think
there's discussions about culture I
think there's you know all this great
metaphysical stuff in book six and seven
I think that the dialogue with
thrasymicus and the fact that thrasymica
stays around to hear the rest of what
Socrates has to say is important you
know all of those things are are
worth reading and discussing and I think
I saw them as kind of sidelines
in the past
um
let's see we're getting a little bit low
on time so I don't know if I'll get to
everybody's questions but we're getting
kind of close to the the end Kenora
what's the book you just couldn't get
through for whatever reason
um
that's a good question
I mean I never read all of James Joyce's
Ulysses in part because I found it so
pretentious playing around with language
and I just after a certain point I was
like I don't want to read this [__] you
know people talk about how great this is
but
God there's so many other things I could
be doing with my time so that that's one
example right there you know
I'm sort of confused do you have any
tips for trying to understand Concepts
uh experiential Concepts which invade a
sort of exact representation
no because I I don't know what that I
don't really know what those
words mean uh euts are there other
thinkers that contributed to Virtue
ethics I know Aristotle was the main
person for it but are there other people
who developed it yeah Aristotle wasn't
the main person for IT Aristotle is one
of many I think what you've gotten
misled by are the the people in uh 20th
century analytic philosophy and then
their followers in the 21st century who
were like Aristotle's we have the you
know Renaissance of Aristotelian ethics
no I mean if in the ancient period era
the aristotelians were just one of many
schools of virtue ethics
virtue is important for Plato uh again
you know discussed in the Mino the
Republic there's there's uh dialogue
specifically on per particular virtues
right
um so massively important and then
there's the entire platonic tradition
carrying on through Middle platonism
With You know the handbook of platonism
by okinus plutarch's many many Works
discussing virtue all the way into
neoplatonism
um so that's another massive tradition
just as important as the Aristotelian
the stoics just as important epicureans
even are focused on virtue the cynics
were into virtue
uh you know all these important early
Christian writers taking up the concepts
Augustine boethius you know all the way
into people like Thomas Aquinas uh
virtue remains an important topic for so
many other thinkers in the modern era
for example you know Mary Wollstonecraft
is a virtue ethicist virtue ethics never
goes away except in this little
parochial area that we call analytic
philosophy there's still people in the
20th century like in the Thomas
tradition like you know Eve Simone
writing you know about moral virtues so
there's like tons and tons and tons of
people Aristotle is just one of them
um
let's see just skipped a little bit
Casper says if you listen to to the
nietzsa podcast I haven't
um unfortunately I mean I don't listen
to a lot of people's podcasts who's got
the time right if I'm generating stuff
um
all right so
we got about four minutes or so because
I've got to do some other stuff today
let's see what I can take and get into
here
um
so here's an interesting thing by Tobias
does philosophy contradict the concept
of God's plan no
no if God has a plan and we can never
fully understand it what's the purpose
of philosophy part of the plan right I
mean why why uh why would this be a
contradiction there I think what you're
setting up two things it's sort of like
saying you know we got the world and we
got apples and uh they're not exactly
the same thing and we can't know the
whole world so therefore no apples so I
would rethink that
um
oh uh Marco I'm interested in middle
platonism so I'd like to ask you how you
would suggest starting with plutarch's
philosophical Works getting your hands
on them they're mostly available online
uh there is no starting point there is
no like here's the the book to read
first just start reading around in them
I mean you'll see the titles and so like
if you're interested in virtue ethics
there's like on virtues and vices if
you're interested in Friendship how to
tell a flatterer from a friend you know
if you're interested in in the question
of anger on controlling anger there's
there's all sorts of people but I will
say this there's a lot that Plutarch
wrote so there's a lot that you can you
can dig into
oh Zach here's a good one I'm officially
a philosophy Professor now so
congratulations on that teaching next
semester very excited any advice on
getting students to be interested in the
profession
um
be interested in the profession of being
philosophy professors that's a hard sell
I would I would say the first thing
you're going to do is get them
interested in philosophy and the way
that you do that at least I mean there's
lots of ways to do that but the way
that's worked best for me is
um be relatable you know realize first
off that
you're not there to like sell them on
becoming philosophy Majors or anything
like that show them that the stuff that
you're studying actually has some useful
application to the problems that they
face as college students in their life
you know be willing to talk about the
student debt that they're taking on or
the fact that you know you think about
teleology whenever we talk about
Aristotle and and you know Nick McCain
ethics book one I bring up why are you
here at College in the first place you
could be out there earning money doing a
job
um you know you think that this degree
is going to lead to a happy life how do
you know that right what does a happy
life look like for you
that sort of stuff I think really helps
to sell philosophy is something that
they um
they can they can find valuable and and
it really is about them finding it
valuable because you can tell them all
you want oh man this has changed my life
you're just some guy walking in there
you know telling them stuff there's no
reason why they have to believe you show
them that it is right
let's see if I can take one other uh
good one
um
there was one I saw a little bit earlier
okay let's let's take this one
um
Max says I'm in a limbo and
procrastinating since I'm figuring out
how and where to go after graduating
from college concerning jobs how should
I slowly approach this issue have you
been through this also you know I
suffered from what was called senioritis
which is a sort of burnout that that
happens for college students your senior
year
and I just worked some what we would
call dead-end jobs you know I worked in
a gas station in part because it gave me
time to read and listen to music and you
know the I didn't have to take my work
home with me and then I came down here
to Milwaukee and worked as a temp for a
mortgage company for a while and that
was pretty miserable and then I worked
as a security guard and a barista and
again you know gave me plenty of
exercise and time to do things
um it's okay to take on like you know
temporary work just to like keep a roof
over your head and stuff like that
um while you think about what you want
to do and this is again I brought up the
word teleological just in a previous
answer this is you figuring out ends and
means what what kind of job would you
like to have and then you think about
well
what do I have to do to
to move towards that job right
so
um
the other thing to keep in mind is that
you're dealing with
an environment where jobs you know often
take a lot of work to get
ironically right because the job is
about work you're going to do it's not
so easy it's just like looking in the
paper and seeing a want ad and then you
know calling them up and coming in with
a
resume
and filling out an application
there's a lot of Hoops to jump through
especially the higher up the job gets
um but you know here's something you can
keep in mind you are not your job if
you're an American but this is also in
other places there is a huge tendency to
identify yourself with the job that you
have right and
um you're not your job any more than you
are your bank account or your car or
anything like that
um you're somebody who can get a job and
do a job and it may not be ideal but you
know if it provides you with an income
if you have other people depending on
you for that income then that's a that's
a good thing right
um and so I would say you know try to be
very realistic about these things and uh
for giving towards yourself
um it's natural to procrastinate
procrastination nobody procrastinates
because they want to procrastinate right
it's always a sign of other stuff going
on so think to yourself why am I
procrastinating you know
um is it because I'm worried about
rejection is it because I'm disappointed
with
getting out of college and things not
falling into place is it that I'm being
there's two P's that often go together
procrastination and perfectionism I'm
like trying to you know if I can't find
the the ideal job I don't want to uh a
crappy job or something like that
um Thomas points out fear of
responsibility that might be something
in the background who knows but
exploring those things for yourself
could be could be quite helpful
and um
you know talk with other people I mean
this takes some vulnerability and it's a
risk but I mean if if your parents are
around and they're receptive or aunts
and uncles older people who've gone
through similar things you know uh bring
it up with them and be like hey do you
ever do you ever run into this
um you got any advice for me
sometimes they can surprise you
and you know I will say too that
um reaching out to other people
is an important part of adult life and
the advice that you get from these these
people after you've moved through
different
life transitions different Milestones
can be
quite different and reveal a different
relationship that you have with them
um down the line but there's probably
other you know recently graduated
college students that you might chat
with as well that you could maybe get
some if not helpful advice at least some
like solidarity like oh man you know I
know what that's like
um
so that's that's where we'll close uh I
I didn't get to everybody's stuff but as
I mentioned I got another event coming
up and then I've got to go drive a while
to go for a hike
but thanks for all the questions and
comments it's been another enjoyable AMA
and uh hopefully this helps some of you
out I see some hearts coming up I'm not
sure how that works on YouTube uh but uh
I guess good to see
um so I will see you next time we got
some other cool stuff tomorrow doing a
reading of one of my favorite short
stories and then we got lots of other
online events coming up this month and
we'll do another AMA next uh month
usually first Saturdays of the month so
I will see you there